- Last season,
we had Connie's Friday
Night Lights husband,
who I love as well,
(Connie laughs)
Kyle Chandler,
and we had him on, and he told this story
about working with you, let's take a look.
- Connie and I, when we'd
be working on the set,
'cause we'd improv every once in a while,
and I would also bring fights that my wife
and I would have that
were sort of unresolved,
and I would create them again on the show.
- I mean, here's the thing.
Just look at him.
- [Connie] He's so cute.
Isn't he cute?
He's so cute.
- I love that he said that he
would take things from home.
Did you ever improvise with
things in your own life?
- Oh, well you know it's
hilarious that he said that,
because we did so much improvisation.
- [Kelly] Which is why it was so great.
- Well, and also,
I'll just say this,
even though this is not
answering your question,
but we'll get back to that.
We played husband and wife.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he had, he has
such an amazing marriage.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They were so inspiring,
and I feel like he brought a lot of that
into the work that we were doing.
- Wow.
- And so it was really
wonderful 'cause it felt like,
it felt like he was really
sharing that with us.
Not in a weird way.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But there's one thing that I think about
when we talk about improvising.
We had this scene once.
I don't know if you remember it
or how much of a Friday
Night Lights head you are.
- Saw every episode.
- But there was a scene where our daughter
and Matt Saracen are watching
a movie on the couch,
and Kyle goes in and
he just like freaks out
and they have a blanket,
and he takes the blanket
away from them.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He's like, you gotta get out of here.
And then,
and I'm just.
- What's happening
under that blanket?
- Right, exactly, and
Tammy is just looking,
I'm just looking at him like this.
And I say, you're an idiot.
And that for me was a
throwback to a show that I did
in the nineties called Spin City.
- Love Spin City!
- [Connie] Spin City,
remember with Michael J. Fox?
- I love Spin City.
- That was the first TV show I ever did.
And we, as a term of endearment,
the actors on that show,
we'd always be like, you're an idiot.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I brought that into,
that was my contribution
to Friday Night Lights.
- One word, one third.
- You're welcome,
you're welcome.
(Kelly laughs)
- Calling him an idiot.
- I love it.
I love everything you do, I'm not kidding.
I love Spin City.
But my son is five and your son is 10.
So what do I have to look forward to,
and what should I be scared about?
- Okay, okay.
- 'Cause I already feel
like we're headed to the ER
like every day.
- Okay, well that's not gonna change.
- Yeah, he's just wild.
He wants to be Peter Pan, yeah.
You can't fly.
- [Connie] Oh he wants
to be Peter Pan?
- Can't fly baby.
- Oh no.
Oh dear, well let's keep trying.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Oh, nope.
(Kelly laughing)
Well, that's unfortunately
not gonna change,
I don't believe.
- Yeah, great, okay.
Truth, I like it.
- It is fun.
Like this sort of 10 year old age,
you can tell that they're
really starting to
think for themselves
and have a sense of who
they are in the world,
and think about other people around them.
It's a subtle shift,
but suddenly it's like,
oh I want to have a conversation with him.
I want to hang with him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I want to hang with him,
and have conversations with him,
and know who he is.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he's so smart.
Like he comes up with,
he can give directions
like nobody's business.
He'll have observations about things
that I never even thought about before.
- That's what I love about kids.
- [Connie] Yeah, I know.
- Yeah.
- And it just kind of gets better
and better that way, I think.
So I'm just gonna tell myself that way
and it's gonna I'm sure
be that way all the way
through the teenage years.
- Totally, you'll have no issues.
- No, no, no, no.
It's gonna be just like that.
- So easy.
So wait, when you were
living in Nashville,
what was your favorite place to hang out?
- Oh
gosh.
- Mine was actually
Bluebird before it was like,
everybody knew about.
- [Connie] Really?
- Everybody in Nashville
knew, and country,
but I did love, anytime I
could see the Time Jumpers,
they played The Station Inn I think.
- Oh yeah, totally.
- And then I'd go to Bluebird Cafe.
But it was before it blew up or whatever.
Now everybody's there all the time.
- [Connie] I know, I know.
- But I love like all the,
you can see music everywhere.
- The Bluebird is, I know,
well I love the Ryman.
- Oh my gosh.
- I would say the Ryman
is one of my favorite places.
That feels like church to me.
- To hear a show is great.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
And we got, you know, we were so lucky,
we got to shoot there so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm sure you
played there a bunch.
- I have played there,
but I'm telling you what,
the coolest show you got to be a part of
and do all these cool things in Nashville
that artists die to do.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- I know, it was really,
I will always look back at
that period of time for me
and just be like, I
cannot believe I got to
have that be part of my life.
- Yeah and it's a fun little community.
But do you still make music
like you did on the show?
I mean, once you start doing that
isn't it kind of a part of you?
You don't find yourself
doing anything like that?
- I'm back to what's
prompted me to have the nerve
to say yes to Nashville
in the first place,
which is basically just
singing around the house.
- Okay, but that's fun.
- Yeah, it's fun, it's great.
- Yeah.
- And singing with my kids,
singing with Yoby.
He's now very musical.
I really do believe 'cause
he grew up in Nashville.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- While I was doing that
show and he now loves music.
- What a cool thing you've done for him.
Growing up around that.
- It's one of those things, I don't know,
nature, nurture is always
so hard to figure out.
- See which one, yeah.
- I don't know if maybe
it really did impact him
or maybe he was just always gonna be
destined to love music.
- Yeah.
- So we sing together a lot.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- And love to listen to music.
- There is nothing sweeter
than singing with your kids
and hearing their little voice.
- [Connie] Oh my gosh.
- Like you could sing
for thousands of people
and they're singing along,
but when it's your kids, you're like, ugh.
- [Connie] Yeah.
- I break in such a great way.
- I know.
- What do you all sing around the house?
Do you have favorites?
- Well, he has a playlist.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- That he started when he was like five.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Every time he'd hear a song,
he'd be like Mom put that on my playlist.
And now that playlist is hours
and hours and hours long.
- I love it.
- And it's funny 'cause
it's really evolved.
And now, let's see, what
are some of the ones?
Now he's really into BTS.
Now he's introducing me to music.
- Okay.
My niece loves it.
She's 14 and she loves BTS, all the K-pop.
She's really into it.
- [Connie] Yeah, yeah.
Okay, that's what that is?
- I'm like okay,
I get into it, I sing it at the house.
I'm like cool, all right.
- Yeah.
He also loves country music.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which I'm sure was probably
the Nashville influence,
but he likes pretty much everything.
So it's like a little eclectic mix.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- And he'll listen to it every day.
- Oh my God, the same song
over and over and over.
- Yeah.
Over and over and over again.
Yes.
- Cool, we're hearing it
again, that's exciting.
- Okay.
- I didn't get it the first 50 times
but now I've got the whole song down.
- I learned it, never knew
I wanted to know a BTS song,
but now I know all the words.
- But now I can do the dance moves.
- [Connie] Yes, yes.
- I love that this was my dance move.
(Connie laughing)
Such a mom at this point.
- [Connie] I feel like
it's right for K-pop.